never a break in this league and kind of
fun i like i like when people ask me hey
what do you do in the off season i say
what off season there is no off season
anymore because we always have something
yeah i had somebody ask me tonight so do
you have some time off now until the
season starts i said no but i but but
again but not a complaint because we're
not working i think we both would agree
on that that writing and talking about
football and watching football games and
going to football practices none of that
is work i've had real jobs and this
isn't a real job so uh and and i guess
you know that that's a nice building
excuse for when we screw up because then
we can say hey it's not a real job what
do you expect from me but our job for
now is to take a closer look at what's
going on with the dallas cowboys because
uh look they're always going to be
one of the main teams that we focus on
in the nfl america's team whether
they're good whether they're bad whether
they're in the middle somewhere and
there's a very high expectation this
year sharing every time i turn around
whether it's stephen jones jerry jones
whether it's ezekiel elliott there's a
lot of people that believe the cowboys
are going to be one of the best teams in
the nfl this year what have you seen so
far that would cause you to say
that yes that's legitimate or maybe
there's reason for concern
well i think yes it's legitimate on
paper because just when you start
looking at hey they're starting 22 from
that postseason game or coming back and
then you look at they got jason witten
back at tight end and i don't you know
he's going to play 20 25 snaps a game
but his leadership in that locker room
can't be underestimated and then you've
got travis frederick coming back at
center one of the best centers in
football plus the things that they've
added to this football team robert quinn
is going to add to that pass rush if
they get randy gregory back from
suspension which they think they will
that pass rush is going to be really
really good
the linebacker position i think they're
probably the last best linebackers of
football the only position you start to
question is its safety did they do
enough at safety to address that
position uh in the off season but they
may get away with it even if they didn't
this is a really good football team and
i think it's going to come down a lot to
coaching where they and that's the
question mark
how is this offense going to play with
callum moore calling the plays and how
is jason garrett going to do in the last
year of his contract needing probably to
get to the championship game to keep his
job
you get kellen moore who's not all that
far removed from being a player his
first time as an offensive coordinator
as much pressure as jason garrett has
ever had on him although he did go into
a season without a new contract finished
it out got to the playoffs and got his
most recent deal that was back after
that loss to the packers with the dez
cotted game that was a lame duck game
for him and he stuck around but i just
feel like it's getting closer and closer
to uh the end for jason garrett if he
can't deliver on this very significant
potential the team has and the high
expectations that ownership has and you
know one of the reasons there's high
expectations they have one of the best
running backs in football and ezekiel
elliott and what we saw earlier this
week the video from the music festival
in las vegas where elliot got in the
face of a security guard and moved
toward him the guy fell over and then
elliot was cuffed i know the cowboys
aren't troubled by this because really
they can't afford to be but
given the suspension from two years ago
i've asked the league what's going on
with this the league hasn't said
anything which means you know i have to
ask him again and again and eventually
maybe they'll tell me something but
i i i would not just assume that this
goes away because of the fact that
ezekiel already has been on the wrong
side of the personal conduct policy
well i do think it will go away if
there's nothing else here if that's it i
do think it's going to go away i do
think it's also troubling just because
of his history if this was anybody else
who'd never had a suspension never done
anything against the personal conduct
policy we probably wouldn't even be
talking about it we're like oh okay
security guard overreacted this is the
end of it but because it's ezekiel who
served that six game suspension two
years ago we are talking about it and it
is an issue and until the nfl comes out
and says which they never do uh that
that he's okay with this they're not
going to suspend him we're still going
to have that question for a long time
about what's going to happen with this
are they looking into this
but the fact that he has that past
suspension is the very reason why it's a
big deal because the way the personal
conduct policy is written if you're a
repeat offender you are more likely to
face
significant discipline remember the
letter he got in 2017 any further
incidents could result in banishment
from the league and when you look at the
terms the specific bullet points the
prohibited conduct under the personal
conduct policy the first one actual or
threatened physical violence and it's
all in the eye of the beholder what was
he doing what was the interaction with
the security guard there was
intimidation was that threatened
physical violence the guy backed off and
fell down and you could even look at
that there's a little chicken wing
action from ezekiel elliott as the guy
falls down that maybe you could say he
was helped down but
ultimately it's something the league
office decides and we saw how they have
exercised discretion in the past against
ezekiel elliott and i think a lot of us
believe they were too aggressive that
they they didn't give him fair
procedures to try to prove that he was
innocent or at least not as guilty as
they believed and uh i i just think
because of that history we need to watch
this
it could result in another eruption from
mount jerry if they would try to do
anything to ezekiel elliott and we
thought we were past that ugliness
between jerry jones and roger goodell
but until the nfl says
whatever they're going to do if anything
with this we just have to wait and watch
and see because of that history that's
the key and you're right anybody else we
don't care because of ezekiel's elliot's
history we have to pay attention to it
not to make too much light of this but
was it a block or a charge
rex chapman would uh would call that
probably a
probably a block probably a block
although i don't yeah we would do
my favorite twitter account if you don't
know we're talking about check out
rexchapman on twitter.com all right um
dak prescott doesn't have his new
contract and you know we assume he's
going to get one at some point
are the fans in dallas sold on dak
prescott as the 10 years 15 years
starting quarterback as the organization
seems to be
oh my gosh it's really been a funny
offseason and and funny on twitter to
see the fans and there it's it reminds
me so much of tony romo because there is
no gray area it's black and white it's
he's great it's he's terrible why would
you give him a new contract let him play
out and leave or absolutely he's worth
30 million dollars a year and and i
if it wasn't for roma i never would have
seen anything like it but a lot of them
the romo lovers seem to hate dak
prescott and maybe it's because they
feel like he put they that prescott
pushed romo out the door and in a way i
guess he did because it still would be
romo's job otherwise uh but but i've
it's just it's so crazy to me that that
there's these two sides that are just so
opposite and no gray area there with dak
prescott they either love him or hate
him here and and they're going to love
him a lot more if he can deliver on a
super bowl
and that's what got people to love roger
stahlbach and troy aikman and why they
don't love
danny white and and perhaps tony romo as
much as they should
yeah and i i saw something from dak
prescott in the postseason that gave me
a lot of faith that he's ready to take
that stuff i mean the guy's only played
a few years in the nfl and he kind of
got thrust into things quickly he was
great his first year second year so so
last year though
in the in the game against the seahawks
i mean hey it's russell wilson and the
seahawks and dak prescott engineered a
victory on behalf of the cowboys and
then in the game against the rams when
the running game wasn't there like it
usually is i thought dak prescott played
really well and if you can get preschool
to a point where he can deliver without
ezekiel elliott getting 150 yards from
scrimmage that's the kind of quarterback
you need you know most franchise
quarterbacks don't need to have an
ezekiel elliot gaining five yards of
carry and ultimately busting a long run
and breaking the back of the defense
most great quarterbacks do it without
that help and i think we may be seeing
prescott move in the direction where
maybe he can do it without having that
battering ram of ezekiel and if they
ever get to that point
then it is time to start clearing a spot
for another super bowl trophy
yeah no question about it and amari
cooper made a big difference for him
last year you just look at the lar yards
per attempt and they went up
significantly when amari cooper joined
the team against tennessee and in those
last nine games that he played with the
cowboys and i just think amari cooper
made dak prescott a better quarterback
last season and i do think we saw some
signs of that in the postseason and i do
think he's going to be a better
quarterback this season with the mari
cooper in the off season with the maury
cooper all season
i think it makes him a better
quarterback and amari frankly has played
better than dez played with dak prescott
dez had that one great year with tony
roma but i'm saying
the the deck the dez bryant that that
dak played with
amari is better than that guy
and there's enough promise on that team
that jason whitton was lured out of
retirement retired from broadcasting to
unretired in football
and uh
what what can he really add to this team
though i mean what does he have left in
the tank and if he's only going to be
doing limited snaps i mean is it more
leadership is it kind of like quasi
coach what do we really expect him to
contribute to a team that
seemed to be okay without him last year
i think he nailed it it's a quasi coach
they're paying for that leadership in
the locker room i think it's the same
thing they're doing on defense with sean
lee and they made this big deal about
how he's going to be the starter at
strong side linebacker come on now they
don't start three linebackers in most
games damien wilson did start nine games
last season but i think we're going to
see sean lee start about half the game
so he's a starter in name only i think
jason witten's a starter in name only
they're paying leadership for those guys
on offense and defense to show these
young guys how it's done this is a young
people don't realize how young this
football team is this is a really really
young football team that is built to win
over the long haul the cowboys have done
a great job of drafting guys and they
did a great job of getting amari cooper
in here
during the season last season young
football team that's built to win for a
long time and these two guys are going
to be paid for their leadership
abilities more than what they do on the
field
and if they win the division this year
one of the teams the cowboys will have
to overcome in the nfc east washington
what has washington done this offseason
to try to inject themselves into the
discussion
in the division in the conference and
maybe get back to an nfc championship
game for the first time since 1991
examination of the washington off season
right after this on tft live
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports